nuclear fusion is a source of energy
it's cheap Clean safe so easy access to
fuel and virtual Unlimited Supply no
production of greenhouse gases little
radioactive waste produced allegedly uh
can you sort of elaborate why it's cheap
clean and safe I'll start with the
easiest one cheap it is not cheap yet
because it hasn't been made at a
commercial scale right flies when you're
having fun yes yeah yeah
but yes not yet but we'll talk about it
actually we'll we'll come back to that
because it it this is cheaper or or a
more technically correct term that is
economic that it's economically
interesting is is really the primary
challenge actually a fusion at this
point
um but let me get back to that so what
were the other ones you said um so cheap
actually when we're talking about cheap
we're thinking like asymptotically like
if you take it Forward several hundred
years uh that's sort of because of how
much availability there is of resources
to use of the fuel you have the fuel we
should separate those two the fuel will
all the fuel is already cheap it's
basically free right what do you mean by
basically free so if if we were to be
using fusion
um fuel sources to power your and it's
like that's all we have is fusion power
plants around and we were doing it the
fuel costs per person or something like
10 cents a year it's like it's free okay
this is why it's hard to in some ways I
think it's hard to understand Fusion
because people see this and go oh if the
fuel is free this means the energy
source is free because we're used to
energy sources like this so we you know
we spend resources and drill to get gas
or oil or we chop wood or we make coal
we find coal or these things all right
so Fusion this is what makes fusion and
it's also
um it's not an intermittent renewable
energy source like wind and solar so
it's like but this is this makes it
harder so you're saying the fuel is free
why isn't the like why isn't the energy
source free and it's because of the
necessary Technologies which must be
applied to basically recreate the
conditions which are in stars in the
center of stars in fact so there's only
one natural place in the universe that
fusion fusion energy occurs that's in
the center of stars so that's going to
bring a price to it depending on the the
cost and sorry the size and complexity
of the technology that's needed to
recreate those things and we'll talk
about the details of yeah both
Technologies in which parts might be
expensive today and which parts might be
expensive in 200 years exactly it will
have a revolution I'm certain of it um
so about clean so clean is at its heart
what it does is convert it basically
converts hydrogen into it's it's it's
heavier forms of hydrogen the one the
most predominant one that we use on
Earth and converts it into helium and
some other products but primarily helium
is the product that's left behind so
helium safe inert gas you know in fact
that's actually what our sun is doing is
eventually going to extinguish itself
because it'll just make so much helium
that it doesn't it doesn't do that so in
that sense clean because there's no
there's no emissions of of carbon or
pollutants that come directly from the
combustion of the fuel itself and safe
safe yeah
we're talking about very high
temperatures yeah yeah so this is also
the counter-intuitive thing so you I
told you temperatures which like 50
million degrees or it actually tends to
be more like about 100 million degrees
is really what we aim for so how can 100
million degrees be safe and it's safe
because it is
this is so much hotter than anything on
Earth where everything on Earth is at
around 300 Kelvin you know it's around a
few tens of degrees Celsius
and what this means is that in order to
get a medium to those temperatures you
have to completely isolate it from
anything to do with terrestrial
environment it can have no contact like
with anything on Earth basically so this
means what we this is the technology
that I just described is it
fundamentally what it does is it takes
this Fuel and uh it isolates it from any
terrestrial condition so that it has no
idea it's on Earth it's not touching any
object that that's at room temperature
including the walls of the containment
even including the walls of the
containment building or containment
designs or even air or anything like
this so so it's that part
um that makes it safe in this and
there's there's actually another aspect
to it but that that fundamental part
makes it so safe
um in in the main lines
approach diffusion is also that it's
very hot but there's very very few
particles
in at any time in in the thing that we
view the power plant and the actually
the more correct way to do it is you say
there's very few particles per unit
volume so in a cubic centimeter and
cubic meter or something so we can do
this so right now we're although we
don't think of air really as there's
atoms floating around us and there's a
density because if I wave my hand I can
feel the air pushing against my face
that means we're in a fluid or a gas
which is around us that has a particular
number of atoms per cubic meter right so
it's about this actually turns out to be
10 to the 25th so this is one with 25
zeros behind it per cubic meter so we
can figure out what a cubic like cubic
meters about like this yeah the volume
of this table like the whole volume
um okay very good so like Fusion there's
a few of those so Fusion like the
mainstream one of fusion like what we're
working on at MIT will have a hundred
thousand times less particles
per unit volume than that so this is
very interesting because it's
extraordinarily Hot 100 million degrees
but it's very tenuous
and what matters from the engineering
and safety point of view is the amount
of energy which is stored per unit
volume because this tells you about the
the scenarios and that's what you worry
about because when those kinds of
energies are released Suddenly It's like
what would be the consequences right so
the consequences of this are essentially
zero because that's less energy content
than boiling water
because of the low density because of
the low density so if you take water is
at about 100 million to a billion times
more dense than this so even though it's
at much lower temperature it's actually
still it has more energy content so if
for this reason
um you know one of the ways that I
explain this is that if you imagine a
power plant that's like powering
Cambridge Massachusetts like if you were
to which you you wouldn't do this
directly but if you went like this on it
it actually extinguishes the fusion
because it gets too cold immediately
yeah so that's the other one and the
other part is that it does not and
because it works by staying hot rather
than a chain reaction it can't run out
of control that's the other part of it
so by the way this is what very much
distinguishes it from fission it's not a
process that can run away from you
because it's it's basically thermally
stable
what does thermostat means that means is
that you want to run it at the
optimization in temperature such that if
it deviates away from that temperature
the reactivity gets lower and and the
reason for this is because it's hard to
keep the reactivity going like it's a
very hard fire to keep going basically
also it doesn't it doesn't run away from
you it can't run away how difficult is
the control there to keep it at that it
varies from from concept to concept but
in generally it's fairly it's fairly
easy to do that and the easiest thing it
can't it can't physically run away from
you because the other part of it is that
there's just at any given time there's a
very very small amount of fuel available
to fuse anyway so this means that that's
always intrinsically limited to this so
if it even if the power consumption of
the device goes up it just kind of burns
itself out immediately yeah so you are
the just to take a tan another tangent
on tangent you're the director of mit's
plasma science and fusion Center uh
we'll talk about maybe you can mention
some interesting aspects of the history
of the center in the broader history
of MIT maybe brought a history of
Science and Engineering in the history
of human civilization but also just the
link on the safety aspect you know
um
how do you prevent you know some of the
amazing reactors that you're designing
how do you prevent from destroying all
of human civilization in the process
what's the safety protocols Fusion is
um interesting because it's not really
directly weaponizable because what I
mean by that is that you have you have
to work very hard to make these
conditions at which you can get energy
gain from from fusion
um and uh this means that the the when
we design these devices with respect to
application in the energy field is that
they you know you
the while while they will because
they're producing large amounts of power
and they will have hot things inside of
them this means that they have like a
level of industrial Hazard which is very
similar to like you would have like in a
chemical processing plant or anything
like that and any kind of energy plant
actually has these as well too
but the underlying under underneath the
core technology like can't be directly
used uh in in a nefarious way because of
the power that's being emitted it just
basically well if you try to do those
things typically it just stops working
so the safety concerns have to do with
just regular things that uh like
equipment malfunctioning uh melting of
equip like all this kind of stuff that
yeah it has nothing to do with Fusion
necessarily yeah I mean usually what we
worry about is the viability because in
the end we build pretty complex objects
to realize these requirements and so
what we try really hard to do is like
not damage those components which but
those are things which are internal to
the to the fusion device and and it's
this is not something that you would
um consider about like it would as you
say destroy human civilization because
that release of energy is just
inherently limited because of the fusion
process so it doesn't say that there's
zero so you asked about the other
feature for that it's safe so it is the
process process itself is intrinsically
safe but because it's a complex
technology you still have to take into
account consideration aspects of the
safety so it produces ionizing radiation
instantaneously so you have to take care
of this which means that you Shield it
you think of like your dental X-rays or
or treatments for cancer and things like
this we we always Shield ourselves from
this so we get the beneficial effects
but we minimize the harmful effects of
those so there are those aspects of it
as well too